Christians claim that Jesus is God the
second person of the Trinity the Divine
son of the father and yet in the Gospel
of John 5: 30 Jesus says I can do
nothing on my
own does it make any sense whatsoever
for God to say that he can't do anything
on his
own this verse was popularized by Muslim
apologist following Nike they usually
quote the King James translation I can
of my own self do
nothing you
see God is all powerful Jesus says he
can't do anything on his own does this
sound like something God would
say Muslims around the world now quote
John 5:30 to show Christians that we got
our theology wrong we somehow missed
this clear verse for nearly 2,000 years
fortunately for us Muslim apologists
found the verse and shared it with us to
correct our dumb
theologians when our Muslim friends
bring up this verse it may be helpful to
ask a quick question the question I
would ask Muslims Who quote John 5:30 is
this can you tell me one word Jesus said
in the rest of John chap 5 can you tell
me a single word word from the rest of
the chapter because if you're quoting
John 5 to show that Jesus was a mere
human being I don't think you've
actually read the
chapter this is an ongoing problem with
Islamic apologists if I were to quote a
Quran verse out of context in a way that
completely distorts the meaning they
would suddenly understand the importance
of reading an entire passage but when
they go to the Bible the most basic
fundamental rules of interpreting a text
go out the
window let me show you what I mean so
Jesus says in John 5:30 I can do nothing
on my own our Muslim friends insist this
verse proves that Jesus was just a man a
helpless human being certainly not God
but last time I checked if we're reading
verse 30 of a chapter there are 29
verses that come before it in that
chapter
perhaps we should look and see what
those verses say so we can make sure
we're not twisting the words of Jesus
our Muslim friends respect Jesus and
wouldn't want to misrepresent what he
said right so they'll definitely want to
read the passage carefully with us won't
they I'll just summarize the first 15
verses of John 5 Jesus heals a man on
the Sabbath and this upsets the Jewish
leaders they regard miraculously healing
someone as work and you're not allowed
to work on the Sabbath we'll pick up the
story in verse 16 this is verse 16 of
the same chapter Islam's greatest
apologists go to when they want to
debunk Christian
Theology and this was why the Jews were
persecuting Jesus because he was doing
these things on the Sabbath but Jesus
answered them my father is working until
now and I am
working uh-oh it's the Sabbath but Jesus
says that he's working because the
father is working this might not seem
like a big deal to someone in the 21st
century but it was a huge deal to first
century Jews Jews weren't allowed to
work on the Sabbath however there was a
debate among the Jewish rabis about
whether God works on the Sabbath some of
them reasoned that since God upholds s
and sustains the universe even on the
Sabbath God works on the Sabbath Jews
don't get to work on the Sabbath but God
works on the Sabbath that was their
reasoning how does Jesus answer the
Jewish leaders when they complain that
he's working on the Sabbath he says my
father is working until now and I am
working like father like son as the
saying
goes now if rabbis are discussing the
Sabbath and they conclude that even
though they're not allowed to work on
the Sabbath God works on the Sabbath and
some guy comes along and says yeah
that's why I'm working on the Sabbath
like father like son what does it sound
like he's
claiming it sounds like he's putting
himself in the same category with God
rather than in the mere human being
category and as the next verse shows
that's exactly what the Jewish leaders
thought he was saying look at the
Heading by the way Verse 18 this was why
the Jews were seeking all the more to
kill him because not only was he
breaking the Sabbath but he was even
calling God his own father making
himself equal with
God calling God his own father making
himself equal with God
in the Bible people or groups of people
can be called sons of God or children of
God in various senses for instance we're
all children of God in the sense that
God created all of us this is the basis
for Ahmed D Dot's Sons by the tons
response oh you claim that Jesus is the
son of God but God has lots of sons in
the Bible yeah there are lots of sons of
God in the Bible but the phrase Son of
God is used in very different ways the
question is is what does the phrase Son
of God mean when it's applied to Jesus
does it mean something more than when
it's applied to say me in John 5 Jesus
is clearly claiming to be the Son of God
in a very special and unique way when he
says that the father is working on the
Sabbath so he's working on the Sabbath
the religious leaders consider this
blasphemy because he's calling God his
own father making himself equal with God
notice the Jews here think that Jesus is
claiming to be a separate God a separate
deity he's the son who's equal with God
but who can act on his own separate from
the father they think he's claiming to
be another God who's equal to God now if
our Muslim friends are right about Jesus
and he's a merely human Prophet how
should he respond when the Jewish
leaders conclude that he's claiming to
be another God who who's equal with God
shouldn't he correct the
misunderstanding of the Jewish leaders
by saying wait you think I'm claiming to
be another God who's equal to God you
totally misunderstood me I'm only human
just like the rest of
you if our Muslim friends are right
that's how Jesus should respond but if
Christians are right and Jesus is the
Divine son who has the nature and
attributes of God and who is one with
the father he should correct their
misunderstanding by saying wait you
think I'm claiming to be a separate God
I'm not claiming to be a separate God
yes I'm God but I don't act on my own as
some extra deity everything I do comes
from the father because I'm one with the
father so we know how Jesus is going to
respond if Muslims are right and we know
how Jesus is going to respond if
Christians are right let's see what
Jesus does and which view is confirmed
Med by Jesus verse
19 so Jesus said to them truly truly I
say to you the son can do nothing of his
own accord oh no Christians Jesus says
that he can do nothing of his own accord
this sounds very similar to verse 30
where you'll recall Jesus declares I can
do nothing on my own but wait a minute
when Jesus says that he can do nothing
of his own accord does he mean that he's
a helpless human being or does he mean
that he can't do anything separately
from the father because he's one with
the father let's at least read the
entire verse before we decide so Jesus
said to them truly truly I say to you
the son can do nothing of his own accord
but only what he sees the father doing
for whatever the father does that the
son does
likewise Jesus does whatever the father
does what mere human being what mere
Prophet could ever say whatever God does
I do that
too so when Jesus says the son can do
nothing of his own accord is he claiming
to be a mere human being or is he
claiming to be the Divine son who's one
with the father and therefore can't do
anything separately from the father
let's keep reading for the father loves
the son and shows him all that he
himself is doing and Greater Works than
these will he show him so that you may
Marvel for as the father raises the dead
and gives them life so also the son
gives life to whom he will if the father
raises the dead so does the son
why because as Jesus said whatever the
father does that the son does likewise
like father like son let's continue for
the father judges no one but has given
all judgment to the
son here we have a theological Red Alert
Jesus says that the father judges no one
but has given all judgment to the son
thus son is the final judge but
according to the Old Testament God is
the final judge in Chapter 3 of The Book
of the Prophet Joel God declares that
the Nations will be gathered and that he
will sit to judge all the surrounding
Nations the Quran also claims that God
is the final judge in Surah 22 verse 56
Allah declares the sovereignty on that
day the day of judgment will be that of
Allah the one who has no partners he
will judge between them Allah is the
final judge according to Islam but Jesus
says the father judges no one but has
given all judgment to the
son there are two main possibilities
here either the Bible and the Quran are
wrong and God isn't the final judge
because he's handed all judgment over to
to a helpless human being or God is
indeed the final judge because Jesus is
God and within the nature of the one God
the father has given all judgment to the
son but why would the father give all
judgment to the son Jesus tells us for
the father judges no one but has given
all judgment to the son that all may
honor the son just as as they honor the
father father and son are one but the
father hands all judgment over to the
son so that all may honor the son just
as they honor the Father Tell Me Do we
honor mere human beings the same way we
honor the father of course we don't do
we honor human prophets the same way we
honor the
father absolutely not what is the only
possible basis for honoring the son just
as we honor the Father the only way we
would honor the son just as we honor the
father is if the son has the same nature
and attributes as the father side note
where did Jesus say I am God worship me
common question from Muslims notice
Jesus says that all of us must honor the
son just as we honor the father one one
of the ways we honor the father is
through worship Jesus says that we have
to honor the son in the same way what
happens if we don't the verse continues
whoever does not honor the son does not
honor the father who sent him do our
Muslim friends honor the son not a bit
and According To Jesus since they don't
honor the son they don't honor the
father remember this is the chapter that
Muslim apologists go to in order to
prove that Jesus was just a human
prophet of Islam the chapter that they
go to when they want to defend Islam
condemns them and their prophet and
their
religion but there's more Jesus declares
truly truly I say to you whoever hears
my word and believes him who sent me has
eternal life he does not come into
judgment but has passed from Death To
Life truly truly I say to you an hour is
coming and is now here when the dead
will hear the voice of the Son of God
and those who hear will
live wait a minute Jesus is the one who
raises the dead I wonder if he simply
means that he raises particular people
when he performs Miracles because if he
means that raises the dead at the
resurrection we are going to have
another theological Red
Alert for as the father has life in
himself so he has granted the son also
to have life in himself and he has given
him authority to execute judgment
because he is the son of
man ha you see there David Jesus calls
himself the son of man this means he's
claiming to be a mere human being just
as Islam teaches so let's ignore
everything else he says and go with
that yeah that works as long as you
completely ignore the fact that the
title son of man as Jesus uses it is a
Divine title for a particular son of man
that the Prophet Daniel sees in a vision
Daniel 7:
13-4 in my vision at night I looked and
there before me was one like a son of
man coming with the Clouds Of Heaven he
approached the Ancient of Days and was
led into his presence he was given
Authority glory and Sovereign power All
Nations and peoples of every language
worshiped him his Dominion is an
everlasting Dominion that will not pass
away and his kingdom is one that will
never be
destroyed I'm a son of man there are
lots of Sons of men but Jesus claimed to
be this part particular son of man
coming with the Clouds Of Heaven who
would be worshiped by All Nations and
peoples and would have an everlasting
dominion and an indestructible Kingdom
watch how the Jewish religious leaders
reacted when they found out that Jesus
was claiming to be the son of man from
Daniel 7 this is at his Jewish trial in
Mark
14 again the high priest asked him are
you the Christ the son of the Blessed
and Jesus said I am and you will see the
son of man seated at the right hand of
power and coming with the Clouds Of
Heaven and the high priest tore his
garments and said what further Witnesses
do we need you have heard his blasphemy
what is your decision and they all
condemned him as deserving
death the Jewish religious leaders
understood what Jesus meant when he
called himself the son of man Muslims
gener generally don't so in John 5 the
chapter Muslim apologists keep going to
when Jesus says that the father has
given him authority to execute judgment
because he is the son of man he's
claiming to be the son of man from
Daniel 7 who will be worshiped by All
Nations including Muslim
nations almost
done do not Marvel at this for an hour
is coming when all who are in the Tomb
Ms will hear his voice whose voice the
voice of Jesus who is according to this
passage the Son of God and the son of
man do not Marvel at this for an hour is
coming when all who are in the tombs
will hear his voice and come out those
who have done good to the resurrection
of life and those who have done evil to
the resurrection of
judgment theological red alerts again
Jesus says that he's the one who raises
the Dead all the dead at the
resurrection according to the Old
Testament who raises the dead at the
resurrection 1 Samuel 2:6 the Lord kills
and brings to life he brings down to
shol and raises up according to the
Quran who raises the dead at the
resurrection sah 22 verse 7
and surely the hour is coming there is
no doubt about it and certainly Allah
will resurrect those who are in the
graves the Bible and the Quran both say
that God is the one who raises everyone
from the dead and yet Jesus claims that
he's the one who raises everyone from
the dead are these the teachings of a
man who thinks that he's a mere human
being just a prophet of God so we've
gone all the way through verse 29 and
now for the very next verse the verse
Muslim apologists quote to show their
followers that even the Bible agrees
with Islam John 5 verse 30 Jesus says I
can do nothing on my own as I hear I
judge and my judgment is just because I
seek not my own will but the will of him
who sent me now that we've read the
passage something Muslim apologists
never ever want us to do pop quiz when
Jesus says I can do nothing on my own I
seek not my own will is he saying a I'm
a helpless human being a simple prophet
of Allah or B when I claimed to be the
Divine Son of God you Jewish leaders
thought I was claiming to be a separate
God who acts on his own but I'm here to
correct you even though I have the same
nature and attributes that the father
has and even though I'm the final judge
of all people and the one who raises the
dead I do not act on my own I cannot act
on my own I can do nothing on my own
because I'm not a separate God I'm one
with the
Father which one is Jesus
saying
how do Muslim apologists read the Bible
they read the Bible like this their
Prophet affirmed the inspiration
preservation and authority of the Bible
so as much as they like to lie they
can't stop going to the Bible but the
Bible contradicts Islam so what do they
do they go to a chapter that thoroughly
contradicts Islam verse after verse
after verse they they ignore everything
in the chapter that refutes Islam they
fixate on a verse that they can twist
into something that seems to agree with
Islam so long as they erase the entire
context and then they Proclaim to their
followers who have never read the
chapter and are therefore in a state of
ignorance that the Bible agrees with
Islam and their gullible followers walk
away thinking that Christianity has been
exposed and that Islam
has been
Vindicated do Muslim apologists approach
the Bible
honestly not at all do they handle the
words of Jesus with respect and
integrity not a bit do they honor the
son As He commands them to honor him
precisely the
opposite so according to Jesus in the
passage that Muslim apologists good go
to when they want to defend Islam do
they honor the
father not even
slightly does John 5:30 support Islam
when you pay any attention whatsoever to
what Jesus is actually saying in the
passage no the passage completely
utterly totally contradicts Islam why do
Muslim apologists go to a passage that
completely utterly totally contradicts
Islam ignore all all of the verses that
completely utterly totally contradict
Islam and then twist the words of Jesus
whom they claim to respect in an obvious
effort to trick their followers into
believing that the Bible supports
Islam why do they do this because they
have to when your book affirms my book
but my book contradicts your book all
you can do is lie when your Prophet
affirms Jesus but Jesus contradicts your
Prophet all you can do is lie dawa is
deception there is no plan
B the question now for our Muslim
friends who are watching is
this since you've
seen as plain as day that your
apologists are
liars since you've seen that they lie to
you about
Jesus are you going to keep following
them away from Jesus and away from the
father or are you going to honor the
son as the father and the son
[Music]
command